era tutti ragazzi e se venite questo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
wired.com tour si chiama ragazzi era
piaciuto così tanto il primo episodio
che avevo fatto decide di fare anche
secondo io c'ero riuscito l'ultima volta
a finire sta roba perché era impossibile
perché devo dovuto farle con lei il
primo livello e dosare le pecore
siamo partiti da dio aveva un senso
soprattutto ragazzi avete cazzo
ok si capisca mi non ha la mano
tremolante tranquilli ma sti cazzi ma
[ __ ] si danno alla sinistra non so
forma per un cazzo disputo tradizione
valleggia
madonna nadal da dal lat al 2 sarò
anch'io ho sbagliato sono finiva a
livello stava anche sbagliando vabbè con
che ragazzi non riuscire a finire
livello che lo devo al tar angelo il
cibo per i 20 ragazzi dove mobilità
cazzo se no no non me la io l'avevo
chiesto ma non me l'hanno dato il
brevetto di volo adesso capisco perché
ragazzi devo rischi ora all'ultimo
miglio roma che sono arrosticini abbiamo
imparato che non so né tosare le pecore
nebo laren e cucinare fantastico samurai
non mi ricordo la posizione no perché
domande ragazzi per favore non fate una
[ __ ] domanda perché la falla scrivere
ragazzi ci sia ma allora siamo rimasti
una tartaruga [ __ ] riceva ragazzi se
veniva sia una tartaruga solido arrivare
alla fine così è impossibile se io ci
provo ma non vi assicuro nulla va bene
ok perfetto una vera centro ma chi se ne
fotte come sto già sudato con iniziato
da tre secondi orecchione poi la
scansione ad oggi la roma con q perfetto
ragazzi basta cazzo ma non riesco a
farlo questo non riesco cucina cucinata
una bistecca
queste sono soddisfazioni cazzo lascia
andare
[Musica]
mi faccio io vi giuro che cio landi si
può avere l'ansia per finocchi la canon
è possibile troppo in anticipo greci non
ci fosse che a [ __ ]
non ci posso fare niente è impossibile
arrivare fino al 15 ragazzi siamo siamo
al 13 se dio vuole ce la facciamo
arrivare al 15 è impossibile la spiaggia
c'è una banana da 75 centesimi separava
dal traguardo a spinoso inserisce la
dentiera di merda nota ci siano ragazzi
ci sia non devo perdere se perdo adesso
lancio il lancio telecomando giuro mi è
rimasta una cazzo di tartaruga ce la
posso fare allora
sembra che mi capita che io sono alla
guida le salite su un taxi io sono
davanti
i ragazzi scendete scendete a
prescindere perché assoluto lei non
riesca a capitare una cazzo di strada e
l'ultima volta sono morto un deficiente
perché saranno nelle cazzo di scimmie
che adesso dovrebbero apparire che sono
apparse dal nulla non so perché se
riuscissi ecco le fila tutta nei bar
funk jazz e jazz
non ci posso crema casi non ci non e poi
non è vero noi sud non è successo i
ragazzi abbiamo sbloccato il mio
preferito dopo secoli jimmy di e sarebbe
allora io me lo presentero tra poco
perché è un figo che non avete idea però
prima ragazzi di rockstar o la mia ho
sbloccato ping pong chaplin found su
guario fatemi capire a io devo devo
saltare ma che cazzo di gioco erika cioè
io dopo aleggiare con la racchetta ma mi
sembra mi sembra una cosa normale giusto
no no io sono sono un fenomeno si giochi
non avete non avevo dubbi alla calmi
calmi
madonna ok
ok si no no sono ok ragazzi ve lo
presento lui è jimmy cioè un gran figo
su questo non c'è dubbio prima di
cominciare con lui mi atmi attrezzo nel
modo giusto
diciamo che carter ad adesso sono
effettivamente pronto che non aveva
senso eravamo d'accordo tutti mi sembra
ma perché cazzo balli quei gatti ma ora
che facciamo finta di niente giochiamo
prima che succeda qualcosa di brutto
disegnato a sostego 7 ma questa ormai
sono un fenomeno nostri segreti ok
il primo è andato dalla cina ma ragazzi
sono curioso di vedere qual è il tuo
spinale di sto cazzo di livello perché
non me lo ricordo io che cosa ho fatto
che cosa ha fatto facciamo la meglio io
ve lo dico non ce la farò metri ma non
importa
[Musica]
ho perso un braccio basta sarà ancora ma
chi a casa ok perfetto buttano di una
più parla ancora quattro vite
impossibile se ancora non ci posso credo
sono morto ancora una volta ai prof
ok perfetto si ragazzi voglio vedere sco
arrivare all'ultimo livello senza senza
morire una volta anche se dubito ma ci
provo
[Musica]
ll ma si dà il caso siamo ragazzi siamo
a 8
si chiama 8 l'autista non ci sta perché
a detta è che ce la possiamo fare se ma
no non è mai successo ma i tagli o
rimasti al 4 posto con quattro vite
impossibile era cosa terminati si no
belli stronzo bene ma papa che pensa se
devi andare a bere vodka sei messo
malissimo zio ma ce la possiamo fare
[Musica]
poi ho fatto un cazzo 14 grigia vinci tu
mi dai nostri padri non sto facendo
niente sono fermo fa tutto lui tiro alla
fune
siamo quasi a 15 legati doccia papa a
buy
ma vai di cache fenomeno ragazzi contro
boston 4 possiamo fare non so non ho
idea di cosa sia ma l'autista di nuovo
non è basta sta cazzo di marty tempo che
calcagni e scaglie gol di franco secco
se il tasto barbiano piano piano piano
la panca piano esiste il freno cazzo
poiché siamo ancora faccia se non corre
in strada non ci posso credere non ci
posso credere che se ci sono le signe
avanti schiaffi rischiate toglietevi dai
con gli art brave calmi dal no
ragazzi io so che è assurdo e assurdo
non so come ho fatto a salvarmi i culi
quel modo ma va bene così mica se mi
pizzica fragoroso che c'era altro
ragazzino sbloccati 3 stavolta sconti
non sono tantissimi facciamo facciamone
un caso non sono anche chi cazzo mi
ricordo questi ragazzi stiamo per
partire per non so dove ma non importa
io mi fido di lui che di sicuro notista
migliore di me su questo non c'è dubbio
non ancora voglio capire madonna ha
deciso questo mica fast and furious
wario edition ragazzi dove stiamo
andando
più che cazzo fa siamo fatti ragazzi
siamo partiti per non so dove
ma non importa a livello 1 ok sono già
pronto sono già compagna devo tagliarci
io volevo arrivare al giorno della mia
vita nel quale in un videogioco avrei
tagliato delle unghie è fantastico
perché cesta musica il mohicano sentendo
la bacchetta multiforme in avanti
solleva la sopra la testa far cadere la
bacchetta multiforme e come lasciare che
la cresta del mohicano sia troppo avviso
non vorremmo macchia dal cresta da
moicano si afflosci mi sembra giusto i
ragazzi il mohicano è la mia preferita
abbiate pazienza
cosa fare si ok campione di squat
ragazzi e fantastico che sa in questo
livello incentrato sui paesi c'è una
cosa pazzesca appiccato vinci bastardo
di merda a casa chi è il numero 1
chiedono uno dei muscoli altro che
batista è una cosa fantastica che
versano un po noi donne dove lo zucchero
con zucchero se si passa bastona che
stava per chiedevo bastonarla gente
ragazzi 4v quattro vite su quattro mai
fatto è la cosa pazzesca campione di
ping pong ragazzino
non temo nessuno non temo un cazzo di
nessuno sono troppo forte è una colpisce
a perfetto che ci siamo 13 35 ragazzi
stiamo andando ai 13 chilometri che poi
quali sono i chilometri che cazzo ogni
volta cazzo si ok non ci posso che
minchia non ci fossero che siamo al 14
non sono morte una volta quadro bozzo
non posso morire adesso non posso
fottutamente morire adesso il mohicano
cazzo così no
ok fai il percorso protetto sorbello c'è
una cosa piegati o dio rega ios è un
macello
adesso adesso documentati così gli ok
perfetto vai vai vai vai vai vai
chi siamo ma perché abbatti che cazzo
abbatto fermi dio santo
l'ho presa nel culo a me lo farei fare a
meno fare i fuochi a ragazzi ci siamo mi
chiamo solo prendendo in testa non ci
posso credere ha già passato ragazzi
come pensano di fare fatemi capire dove
cazzo devo puntare
e cazzo fa un baffo anche l'allora sei
stronzo ragazzi me lo spiegate dove devo
puntare che non si capisce dove cazzo la
puntata le fa le banane
da quando questo spara banane fatemi
capire che cazzo è sconfigge che cosa
sconfitto o dio che quel 3 gara frega
c'è un grosso cosa nero davanti a me non
è normale o di rho è una mega larice e
una me è una mega larice non so perché
cazzo se [ __ ] stronzi la gamma
prima non e sparava le banale per quello
morivo caso no no io veramente non so
per cosa sto facendo nella mia vita qui
per giocare ad un gioco dove devo
sparare ad un naso con un altro nato
[Musica]
c'è mazzarri a mezz'ora cioè livello
durato di più in assoluta al mondo
e pazzesco non c'è più non mi sento qui
la gamba giuro che mi fa malissimo
ok ci abbia fatta già abbiamo fatto
fantastico sono 520 euro per sto
passaggio signorina grazie mille ma dove
cazzo vai vecchiaccio fa cosa non si fa
per pagare il conto meraviglioso non ha
pagato la corsa è lo so lo so lo so
benissimo stai tranquillo ragazzi vado
avanti nel prossimo volevo soltanto
vedere quanto riuscivo a fare tipo di
pale voglio riprovarci costo tennis
perché impossibile ping pong lab è come
qualsiasi cosa sia non importa base
dell'unica cosa voglio vedere se riesco
a fare più di quanto sollecita far prima
anche se è perfetto se io io già così
che siamo all'inizio trovo difficoltà
figuriamoci dopo ea sul caso se si ok 24
che queste jaray condor gage e già
record e già va bene perché mi j league
è incredibile che geestisce madonna 33
38 in questo record mondiale lega
segnatelo che record mondiale assoluto
non ci pazzo e va a falco l'allora cmec
no no no tana di una pallina perfetto
ragazzi ha pure altro che faccio schifo
al tennis ma non lo farò mai più mai e
sudando non sono anche spiegare perché
ma non importa ragazzi concluso più
l'episodio perché vi si sta scaricando
con la batteria le perfetto fantastico
come sapete ragazzi seguiti è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche al
pari facebook e come ogni video
trattenere descrizione senza presidi
scrivetemi ci rivediamo qualcuno vito
era ragazzi